we are trying to grow the repertoire of
things that we know how to differentiate
things that way you know how to find the
derivatives of things that we know how
to determine the gradient functions on
so what I'm gonna do is I want to think
about what happens when you take
functions and you put more than one kind
of function together
there's lots of different ways that you
can combine functions just like there
are lots of different ways you can
combine numbers okay so we're gonna go
through them in ten today actually it's
gonna be a pretty simple one it starts
off simple you'll always think like what
else could it be once you see this
result but part of the point is that
well it could be other things as you'll
see when we have a look at some of the
more complicated ways of combining
functions okay so here's our first one
the derivative of a sum of functions
okay so five sub function s some
function and some function which itself
is a sum okay I'm going to call them U V
U and V not you and me you would be okay
now let's just let's just think about
this for a second just so you don't lose
what's going on you used to see f of X
right
f of X what this really means is F is
the name of the function right if it's
the name of the function and X is the
variable that you put into it right
input okay now we have been looking at
functions with names that have
particular variables all the time okay
so for example one of the most famous
ones that you guys already know is PI R
squared now what is the name of this
fashion it's the area of a circle right
now usually it's kind of unambiguous
that we're talking about a circle so you
take a for area so a is the name of the
function capital
area but an X to be seen right what's
the variable that's input into this
that's the radius right so you would say
a of R equals PI R squared okay so don't
freak out like it's just a name and it's
just variables sometimes you even get
more than one for instance you might
recognize just into the same
neighborhood
you better recognize this what could
this be the volume of a cylinder right
now there's not just one variable that
gets input into this is there right in
fact there's two you need the radius and
you also need the height so just look at
this it's the same idea there's the name
of the function and it just so happens
that in this case you've got more than
one variable that gets input all I want
you to understand is now when you look
at this what does this mean
okay this means you is to name it
function and it also gets X's put into
it and V is another function it also
gets X's prettier these could be
anything for instance this could be like
X cubed okay and this guy could be 2x
all fine okay anything you like any kind
of combination where all you're doing is
you're adding them together sir
having that our piece of notation
obviously if this is what the function
is
then what would its derivative okay
well by definition let's just start with
the definition the derivative of any
function is the limit as H approaches
zero right and and on and on you go okay
so let's just quickly put that
as there's so many other cases and
you've heard me say this before merely
writing down this formula isn't
meritorious doesn't deserve you any
marks but it does help it get in your
head what you're doing right rise over
run tangent not seeking and then you
won't screw it up with the latest stuff
which is what you get awarded marks for
is incorrect because you saw it capable
okay now I know F is right I know what F
is so instead of all of these I can
replace them with what it's really equal
to which is U plus V you've noticed I
stopped saying U of X plus V of X
because I don't need to keep on saying
it they're all functions of X okay so
when I say you you know what I mean okay
it's you being a function so I can say
hey limit as H approach zero okay now
what is f of X plus h right well it's f
of X but instead of X's everywhere you
see X's you put in X plus h so I see you
next there and I see that's there so I
should put in X plus h it's on the
numerator here I've got U of X plus h
plus V of X plus h okay so that little
component there those two terms have
come from there makes it okay in exactly
the same way I am going to subtract f of
X well I know exactly what f of X is
it's this okay
so I could say take away and then put
some big brackets around that but I'm
just going to expand the records do that
more than one here so I've got minus U
of X minus V of X okay so you've got
this part here take away this is just me
substituting that straighted okay and of
course it's all divided
H okay that only takes a slight little
bit of rearrangement here okay can you
see I've got a u-turn here in the
YouTube here okay
and if I just ignored the fact that they
were used for a seconds post there like
FS orgies or whatever letter you'd like
okay X plus h that function there minus
an X that's just first principles isn't
it like it's right there just with a
different letter
so let's rearrange it to make a notable
obvious what's going on okay this is
kind of like what you do when you
rearrange your quadratic to make it
easier to factorize so I've got U of X
plus h here and then take away U of X
gather the use then put the V's over
here now I could stop there could stop
there okay and put all over H but just
to make it even more obvious what's
happening I'm going to write these as
two separate fractions right they both
have the same denominator so I'm gonna
make this one over H and I'm gonna make
this one over H okay with that okay I
will in a second yeah what is it
so what I've got have I got now but I
got no I have the limit as H approaches
0 of this big enormous thing fear
against Pinos thing now well we had a
look at limits before
okay limits are all about well how does
this thing behaving as this happens okay
how's this for him now just think of a
simple limit just think about the limit
as say X approaches 0 oh I don't know
say x squared plus 1 okay now this is a
nice easy thing there are no asymptotes
there are no holes in the function okay
see you like all right here is X square
plus 1 right and whether you come from
below or whether you come from above
you're just going straight to that value
right and of course the intercept is 1
so you know that this is equal to 1 okay
but you can also see this another way
instead of just going straight there and
say okay what's it equal to you can see
that because I
have some in here right I can kind of
think of these two there's two different
things I can think about any more space
I can think about the limit as X
approaches zero of this guy which of
course is just gone is Europe right plus
the limit as X approaches zero of this
guy now this is independent of X there's
no X's in here so it's just gonna do the
same thing I was doing all this light
which is go to one so this is your plus
one
one as we saw before okay so when I have
the limit of a sum you can break this
apart in exactly the same way that I
broke apart this fraction okay so now
rather they have one limit one big thing
I'm gonna think of two limits limit H
approaches zero of this plus another
second limit which is exactly the same
but with these instead of years okay I'm
pretty much there now okay
these lines these lines by definition
are the derivative of U at some point X
this is you - okay and of course this
being exactly the same thing is the
derivative of V at any given point X V -
okay
and of course what I began with is -
thanks okay so what have I concluded I
can commute when you are differentiating
finding the derivative of something
which is some of the functions right the
derivative of a sum is the sum of the
derivatives you say that again driven of
a song like that is this sum of the room
that's it's very very simple you're like
what else could it be
well as we go forward you'll discover it
can be other things right when we
combine them not just by adding right
but by saying like multiply you like
things things go out the window okay so
I like that it's so memorable I'm even
gonna write down encourage you to do
that as well
the derivative of a psalm
the dream of a sum is the sum of the
derivatives in other words when you're
differentiating a big long thing which
is a whole bunch of terms all added
together just take them one at a time
differentiate them individually and add
it comes